foreign definitely my big truck it's
like my baby the F-150 Raptor my car I
bought my car off Craigslist it's a
two-door Honda Civic probably my goyard
bag and then I would say I just love the
Bottega bag that I absolutely love and
would buy again a designer bag mama
loves bags I made a bet with a player on
the team that I would buy a purse if I
made the Olympic roster Alex Morgan made
me go and buy it because I actually
wasn't going to do it an espresso
machine a surfboard jewelry my earrings
that I have in my bracelets I went and I
bought one of those David Yurman Rings
probably my first vacation I went to
Greece with my sister and college
roommate trip to Cabo vacation yes I
would say my dog